[Música]
lo primero que se nos ocurriría es al
qaeda
había una comprensión de la amenaza pero
no estaba tan alto en la lista de
prioridades de nadie
bajamos la guardia la comunidad de
inteligencia no acierta en todo no tiene
poderes adivinatorios
hemos sufrido una gran pérdida en
nuestro dolor y nuestra rabia hemos
encontrado nuestra misión y nuestro
momento
[Música]
ah
es el león del panshir el icono de la
resistencia afgana en su valle el
comandante masud en recorre las líneas
del frente con los talibanes y recibe a
periodistas extranjeros
el 9 de septiembre del 2001 dos
reporteros árabes se acercaron a él
[Música]
louis falling in order to make up
y lo seguimos todo el tiempo para
grabarlo y crear un archivo de él
hay ya fuente to capture de mí así que
ese día tenía mi propia cámara y solo
quería grabar una entrevista a nadal
friend in these two arabes
éramos cuatro yo un amigo y estos dos
árabes
el
comandante les pregunto quiénes son cómo
llegaron a afganistán qué tipo de
preguntas quieren hacerme y al menos una
de las preguntas era así se toma
afganistán que se va a hacer con el
líder de al-qaeda osama bin laden
estuvo ocupado por la cámara durante 15
20 30 segundos yo vi la explosión el
ruido no era tan fuerte como cuando un
balón de fútbol explotara
[Música]
me giré para ver el edificio y que todas
las puertas y ventanas estaban
destruidas y que había un book la cámara
de los falsos periodistas se escapó a la
vigilancia de los guardias los dos
hombres en realidad miembros de al qaeda
ocultaron una carga explosiva
en food estaba con mi abuela yo estaba
sentado a su lado y estábamos en la mesa
mi hermana también estaba con nosotros
cogió una cuchara para comer y se me
cayó de la mano
de repente sentí una gran sensación de
estrés y adrenalina en mis venas
really
esker
estaba muy asustado última abuela me
preguntó qué te pasa no lo sé pero tengo
la extraña sensación de que a mi padre
le pasó algo exactamente en el momento
en que la explosión sucedió a cientos de
kilómetros de distancia de donde yo
estaba
[Música]
de jalisco verlander
el helicóptero aterrizó y el gran
edificio del hospital
y había otro edificio cerca era la
morgue
y el carro en lugar de girar hacia el
hospital giró hacia la morgue
y fue entonces cuando supe que ya no
estaba vivo
[Aplausos]
a pesar de la pérdida de su emblemático
líder los principales dirigentes de la
alianza del norte consiguen mantener
unido el movimiento
los herederos de masud deben enfrentarse
al empuje de los talibanes que ya
controlan casi todo el país
[Música]
working man from the beginning
al qaeda estuvo trabajando con los
talibanes desde el principio al qaeda
pensó en aprovechar la situación para
tener algún tipo de base permanente en
afganistán
así que la ideología era la misma y los
métodos más o menos los mismos
lo que el mundo aún no sabe es que el
asesinato de masud es sólo el primer
paso
[Música]
la especial atención
médica
u2
[Música]
mirando hacia arriba un poco antes de
las nueve vi una enorme nube de humo
ya mí inmediatamente me personas y
estuvimos allí comentando lo que nos
pareció un accidente muy grave cuando
vimos un segundo avión ante nuestros
ojos
[Aplausos]
y as mónaco un fin y en ese momento
comprendimos que no era un accidente
sino que eeuu estaba bajo ataque que
estaba en guerra
[Música]
inmediatamente llamé a mi jefe de
contrainteligencia y le dije que
estábamos siendo atacados
y unos dos minutos después el
vicepresidente me llamó y dijo por favor
bajen a la sala de conferencias segura
tenemos que hablar por videoconferencia
pero enseguida me di cuenta tras el
asesinato de ahmad shah masud de que
eeuu y ciertamente yo éramos culpables
de una falta de imaginación
[Música]
durante años masud el afgano había
intentado advertir a los occidentales
contra la amenaza de al-qaeda lo repitió
incansablemente como durante su visita
al parlamento europeo en estrasburgo a
principios de 2001 o durante una de las
últimas entrevistas aquí un mes antes de
su muerte
si osama bin laden no está ocupado en
afganistán creo que su red hará muchos
daños fuera
y el software por supuesto que
escuchaban pero no tomaban ninguna
medida nueva acción así que en el valle
de panshir queda claro muy rápidamente
que los ataques en eeuu están vinculados
con afganistán del
responsable los responsables del 11-s
son los mismos responsables del
asesinato de mi padre
wendys atrás
enter a vertir y cuando estos dos árabes
entraron a nuestro territorio fue unas
dos semanas antes del 9 de septiembre
mis desde planos
todas s net
del líder
esto significa que habían planeado
asesinar al comandante mucho antes del 9
de septiembre
efe xac si tu duda
de mi ciudad
y lo hubieran conseguido habrían tenido
tiempo suficiente para limpiar
afganistán antes del 11 de enero
puedo decirle curiosamente que cuando
ama salma su fue asesinado a los
talibanes y alegraron mucho realmente
flotando en una nube pensaron esto es
todo la xunta está muerto finalmente así
que vamos a ganar la guerra etc
el principal foco de la resistencia a
los talibanes y al qaeda no ha sido
derrotado se trata de una espina en el
costado de osama bin-laden que sabe
perfectamente que eeuu podrá contar con
estos antiguos soldados de masud en su
respuesta
dentro de la cia los agentes han tratado
desesperadamente en los últimos años de
convertir a al qaeda en la prioridad de
la inteligencia estadounidense pero él
le glee la sede de la agencia la
dirección se hace la de los oídos sordos
para kris urs miembro vocal
reclutó una fuente que era miembro de al
qaeda los reclutamos completamente
trabajaba para nosotros
y de repente me había obligado por orden
del cuartel general de la cia a cortar
todo contacto con él y a dejar de
reunirme con él porque era ciudadano de
un país con el que teníamos relaciones
amistosas
meeting sky
y les preocupaba más que los
descubrieran hablando con este hombre y
dañando nuestras relaciones diplomáticas
que tener una fuente dentro de la propia
década así que tuve que cortar el
contacto
al qaeda está en el punto de mira de
washington desde hace algunos años el
grupo perpetró atentados contra las
embajadas estadounidenses en kenia y
tanzania en
1998 y contra el uss eshkol en 2000 los
espías estadounidenses detectan a osama
bin-laden en varias ocasiones
cuando estaba en afganistán había planes
operativos completos escritos en la cia
para ir a afganistán y deshacerse de él
antia huerta
en el plano original era ir así y
matarlo porque este tipo estaba
dispuesto a matar
porque incluso ya había matado a
estadounidenses y estos planes nunca
fueron aprobados
pero él estaba allí con su familia la
realización de esta operación habría
provocado sin duda la muerte de mujeres
y niños tras el 11-s el enfoque
estadounidense cambió radicalmente no
más sentimientos ni medias tintas
[Música]
quiero que todos sepan que hoy eeuu está
de rodillas rezando por los que
perdieron la vida aquí
puedo oírlos y el resto del mundo puede
unirlos y la gente que destruyó esos
edificios pronto nos escuchara
[Aplausos]
desde la noire will be centro ni
fosforera o resultado el día después del
11-s en 24 ó 48 horas estaba de vuelta
en la sede de la cia y había mucha rabia
en gol
salud
ok seguido de cerca por un bien podemos
quitarnos los guantes ahora podemos ir a
hacer todas las cosas que intentábamos
hacer y que nos impedían hacer porque
bueno es demasiado tarde han muerto
miles de personas pero podemos abordar
de una vez este tema a menos de 48 horas
después de los atentados la cia intenta
desesperadamente infiltrarse lo más
rápido posible en la organización
terrorista para obtener información y
destruir la mejor algunos recuerdan
entonces la antigua fuente de sant fadis
sombra
alguien del centro antiterrorista se
dirigió a mí y me preguntó si sabía cómo
ponerse en contacto con este hombre y
dónde podían encontrarlo lo cual era una
pregunta ridícula
y era un terrorista no mi amigo no mi
hermano no mantuvimos el contacto nunca
supo mi verdadero nombre obviamente no
nos juntamos con cuentas terroristas no
les enviamos tarjetas en navidad donde
esta si tuviera que adivinar diría que
está en algún lugar organizando
operaciones para matar estadounidenses
eso es lo que me imagino
tenemos una gran agencia de inteligencia
pero todavía no somos el mejor servicio
de inteligencia del mundo porque porque
no lo necesitamos no somos israelíes no
nos atacan por todos lados somos una
sociedad libre democrática y abierta con
una frontera abierta al sur vamos que
podría pasarlos y de repente descubres
que el [__] existe
y si tanto demócratas como republicanos
no han prestado suficiente atención a la
amenaza terrorista es porque los tiempos
parecen muy tranquilos
[Música]
y hay que recordar que en la década de
los 90 estamos disfrutando del dividendo
de la paz el muro ha caído hemos
recortado drásticamente la financiación
de nuestra comunidad de inteligencia
sí
el
blog soviético
es cierto que la caída del bloque
soviético el fin de la parte de en
sudáfrica
la idea de que íbamos a llegar a un
acuerdo entre los palestinos y los
israelíes en el proceso de paz iniciado
por rabín y arafat
que
crearon durante un cierto número de
meses largos meses un clima realmente
bastante optimista y luego aceptó la
fifa era el 11 de septiembre el final de
un breve periodo de lo que yo llamaría
euforia sino de tranquilidad
internacional peter national de repente
vaya no tenemos suficientes hablantes de
árabe no tenemos suficientes personas
que hablen persa o las lenguas locales
pero si no tenemos suficiente de lo que
necesitamos
entonces si le he entendido bien dice
que lo que ocurrió el 11-s podría
haberse evitado
sin dudas era completamente evitable
eeuu está descubriendo sus defectos la
conmoción de los atentados aún no ha
pasado pero ya es hora de vengarse
[Música]
nuestro dolor se convierte en ira y la
ira la resolución tanto si llevamos a
nuestros enemigos ante la justicia como
si la justicia bien a ellos se hará
justicia
la primera decisión fue dar a los
talibanes la oportunidad de entregar a
osama bin laden y al qaeda y el primer
mensaje a los talibanes de afganistán
fue si hacen esto pueden permanecer en
el poder tenían un plazo muy corto
dejaron claro que no se voltearían
contra los dirigentes de al-qaeda y así
inevitablemente decidió la acción
militar a líquidos óxido o no
obviamente occidente no pudo entenderlo
lo vio y lo entiendo como un acto de
salvajismo y cuando uno enfrenta a un
animal salvaje que hace pues dispara no
intenta averiguar por qué lo ha mordido
henry nation cada nación en cada región
tiene ahora que tomar una decisión y no
están con nosotros
o están con los terroristas
[Música]